[Music]
it's clear that in terms of optimistic
positivity is predictor of mortality it
does predict mortality and predicts
mortality when you control for lots of
different self-reported health problems
depression scales that have been
validated self-reported health if you're
interested in predicting things from
optimism often optimistic positivity you
want to look at what predicts it and
that's what I was focusing on that first
paper so we have three papers already
started basically we're looking at
explicit measures of optimism as well as
these we're using wording effects to
measure what we're calling an implicit
measures of close to perceptual optimism
and pessimism that positive wording bias
is a form of optimism but if you're
looking at the world in more positive
ways you're taking information in and
you're framing it in positive ways and
you're seeing it so you're reacting to
it in positive ways sometimes in a way
that you you don't even know that you're
doing right so subtle it's like a
wording effect that you couldn't say to
you you know it's not like I'm asking
you are you responding this way to these
words of that those ways in that words
we can detect it statistically over
people so we're asking people to say
things about themselves on a survey for
example you're asking them you know are
you a good person
are you a competent person there's a
whole series of questions you can ask
them some of them will abridge
positively some of them are negatively
and usually those wording those survey
questions are used to to create scales
of things like self-esteem self-efficacy
mastery is a latent variable the idea is
that there's something out there it's
latent and it explains some variants in
how people answer these questions we're
putting that together with some measures
that axpy as people thought how
optimistic they are using language
explicitly and saying that together
those things create this phenomena
and we're saying that the phenomenon
goes deep to the level of perception is
it itself a form of stratification if is
there something about optimism that's
that's a resource that we can't stand as
a psychological good like happiness
right and so if it's stratified in the
population how is it associated with
other kinds of stratification income and
so forth education and so you know
you're saying well class the real
interesting one is class right everybody
wants to know you know pull yourself up
by your bootstraps you know think
positively you'll be successful if
you're optimistic you'll be successful
right but of course if you're successful
you going to be optimistic so there's
the reverse causality thing and so
partial taking a class and looking at
class is really really interesting part
of that I want to get to right and I
think that's an interesting question
because there's a lot of theory around
sociology and emotions around the idea
that expectations are created the
ability to meet expectations generates
energy that energy is what allows people
to do things is something that emotional
energy and then it replicates itself
so people are convinced to be optimistic
especially the middle classes and if
they're not able to achieve those
expectations then that entire energy
goes down and they become too satisfied
there's some difference with cohorts and
oh I see with race difference I see
cohort differences when you were born
and that makes sense in terms of things
like civil rights movements and what you
experienced in your life right and and
you hopes and dreams and and so forth so
the question I'm looking at now first of
course is well you can't change you have
not many not much way that your optimism
your custom is going to change your
gender and a statistically significant
way you know might change people can
change their gender but it's not gonna
change your age it's not gonna change a
birth cohort and you know race very
small effects so I'm looking at those
things
that influence think that can be
understood as causes of and they can't
be reverse causality first so that's
what I've been doing and we ran these
models and what do we see well we did we
saw that when you look at all these
things raised birth cohort age and
gender together that these curves and
the curves are interesting they start
off with men being more optimistic than
women there's a convergence in midlife
and then a divergence again momentum
more optimistic optimistic positivity
higher optimistic positivity than women
right we see erase trends and and those
vary by cohort people born before 1932
whites are more optimistic than blacks
for all these people
optimism optimistic positivity declines
with age right so we're seeing these
trends over time declining with age but
whites are more optimistic than blacks
and is declining but for people born
after 1932 we see blacks having higher
levels of optimist these Americans right
all US data high higher levels of
optimistic positivity than whites over
the over age period they are still
declining time that's optimistic
positivity what about a pessimistic
negativity right blacks consistently
higher than whites in disgust
pessimistic negativity across cohorts so
we can look at those things and say you
know people who got more schooling past
high school you know they were
optimistic when we first measured them
and and they were more likely to get
some schooling and we can try to control
for other things and say it's it's
really the optimism that's influencing
the schooling we could also try to say
you know they're their class background
is influencing their optimism investment
and I think that's we have a better
position to say something about that we
can look at over 25 years we don't have
how what you were born with right we
don't have when you started off with
right we do have what your parents what
income your parents made you know what
school you know how much schooling you
got and so forth I was thinking about
the
was that I really came of age in 1976 as
Great Society programs were in place
there was really opportunity for people
who bass I went to some of a high with
that time it was called slumber velena
hope was in a very it's a place now
that's very houses worth millions of
dollars and so forth but at that time it
was a working-class neighborhood I
wasn't a great student I got into
University I did oh well in university
because the only option I saw was
joining the Air Force of the army and
now I'm a professor right so I was
thinking about my career in the con and
in terms of this project and the
opportunities I've had and I mean I am a
pessimistic person but I took advantage
of the opportunities because I saw that
there were doors the way society is
structured is if there's doors and if
you can jump through them it doesn't
really matter what your skill is that
much their divisions are fine-grained
and if you can get through that door you
get all sorts of resources and then
you're going to get to the next level so
I became optimistic about academia in a
way that allowed me to continue to put
my nose to the grindstone and not to
think too much about it because the
resources were there right I made the
decision yeah I mean it but really the
point I wanted to make was these
policies these programs kids don't have
them anymore like now I teach and and
the kids see that the middle is getting
hollowed out right and they're anxious
mental health problems in university
have gone through the roof right and
universities don't know how to deal with
it so and I can see why they have
because the opportunities aren't there
and the kids realized that there's a
bifurcation right does it make it or
break it
so I look at myself I look at my own
history and I say I was the end tail-end
of the baby boom and
you know I profited economically in some
way socially in some ways but you know
in other ways maybe not and so I look at
these generational differences now and I
can understand now you're going back to
business right going in somebody gets a
job in the gig economy right what's
their mentality like there's another gig
down the road I'll make it work to the
extent I can or is it become like it
this has to really work and if it
doesn't work I'm screwed right my career
I don't really know I don't think
anybody really knows what's happening in
these areas that you're interested in in
terms of work you know and what the
possibilities are there's some
interesting questions that you have to
ask
[Music]